[APPLAUSE]
NATASHA CASE: Thank you guys.
First of all, thank you
so much for having us.
This is really
cool and exciting.
We've been looking
forward to it.
We're big fans of Google.
We use your business platform
in many different ways
since we started.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Google Ads.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
The calendar, Ads,
Drive, everything.
So we're glad to be
able to pay it forward.
And just want to ask how many
of you already know Coolhaus,
have heard of us,
have tried the trucks.
Awesome.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Not bad.
NATASHA CASE: You
should be ashamed
if you didn't raise your
hands, but we'll forgive you.
So, I'm Natasha.
This is Freya.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Hi.
NATASHA CASE: We're here,
we have our cookbook
which just came out in May which
we're really excited about.
100 recipes.
Ice cream cookies,
toppings, other things.
A lot of architecture
background on the punny names
with the flavors
because at Coolhaus,
we're architecture-inspired.
I used to be an architect.
So they have funny
names like Mintimalism,
which we're actually going
to make for you today.
Mies Vanilla Rohe Frank Berry,
which as I'm sure most of you
know, you're in a Frank
Gehry Binoculars building,
so it's particularly apropos
to be talking about ice cream
and architecture here.
And also there's a
lot about our story
in the book about
how we got started
and how we grew the business.
So I hope you enjoy the book.
And we wanted to
kind of basically
show you how to make one
of our favorite recipes
from the book, which is the
Dirty Mint Chip ice cream.
We're going to demo
that for you today.
One of our signature
and original flavors.
Which with a couple different
cookies is the Buckminster
Fuller, or the Mintimalism,
as I mentioned,
is the punny name for that one.
And we're also going to give
you a little bit of history
on our brand.
How we got started,
how we're growing,
and where we're going
with our vision.
So, yeah, we can go
ahead and get started.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: So the first
thing we're going to do
is actually jump ahead in
time a little with ice cream.
As far as the process of how
we are able to make ice cream.
We're going to time travel here.
Because you'll notice
in a lot of the recipes,
the active time is
actually quite low.
It's like 20, 25 minutes.
But ice cream does require a lot
of planning and being organized
over actually what can
be a several day span.
So what I'm going
to do first is I'm
going to take the base,
which I already made,
so this would be base
from the future for you.
Which consists of milk,
cream, in this case,
actually, which
I'll explain when
we're making the base for you,
light brown sugar, and egg
yolks.
So I'm going to go ahead
and get that started.
FREYA ESTRELLER: And
you guys can definitely
follow along in the book.
I don't know-- I think it's
page 40 where the recipe is.
The Dirty Mint Chip ice cream.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah, it's
towards the beginning.
So I'm pouring all this base
I made, I have about a quart
of it, into my ice cream maker.
We love Cuisinart
ice cream makers.
This one is the
commercial grade,
which is a compressor
style ice cream machine.
But that run about $300 from
like a Williams Sonoma or Sur
la Table.
We also recommend in the book
a gel canister [INAUDIBLE]
which are cheaper.
And those run about $50.
You just have to
freeze a container that
has like anti-freeze
in it overnight.
But they're very accessible.
If you get one of
these, you can make
hundreds of ice cream flavors.
So next is we're going to put in
our fresh chopped mint leaves.
We do recommend organic.
In this recipe,
it's really special
because we don't use
any mint oil or extract.
It's just the leaves that
give it the mint flavor.
And that's going to give it
much more of a mojito or mint
tea-like minty feeling.
As opposed to a super
sweet toothpastey
mint which we're not into.
I think you'll agree with us.
Next going in there
is dark brown sugar.
Like a third tablespoon.
Third tablespoon
dark brown sugar.
That's when it also--
FREYA ESTRELLER:
Half tablespoon.
NATASHA CASE: I'm sorry.
That's going to play
to the more kind
of earthy quality of
this particular recipe.
And a little bit,
I think, the salt.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yes.
NATASHA CASE: And
then next, we're
going to put a pinch of
kosher salt in there.
And on this machine, to really
get it to kind of the ice cream
consistency where it's ready to
come out of the machine, that's
going to take almost an hour.
This machine has a handy timer.
So that's why we're getting
started on this now.
Because it's just going to
be churning and churning.
And basically how it
works is as it's turning,
it's adding a little bit
of air to the ice cream.
And it's freezing it.
In ice cream, we
call that overrun.
It's the ratio of
how much base you
put in to how much
output you have.
These machines are
very low overrun.
Very dense, very high butter
fat, the best quality,
the best tasting ice cream.
So that's the one that we
recommend for you guys.
There's one more
step to this, which
we're going to do
at the very end.
Which is our semi-sweet
chocolate chips.
Does anyone know why we
don't put them in right now?
Any geniuses?
FREYA ESTRELLER: Oh, you got it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NATASHA CASE: Exactly.
FREYA ESTRELLER: There you go.
Gravity.
NATASHA CASE: Any
heavier inclusions
are just going to sink right
there and not distribute.
So those are going to
go in at the very end.
But we want our
mint leaves in there
so they can infuse the ice
cream as much as possible.
So now I'm going to jump
forward in time a little bit.
And we're going to show you
how to make the actual base.
So this base that we're making
is essentially a custard.
And, as I said, it consists
of milk, cream, sugar, and egg
yolks.
In this case, we use
brown sugar in the base.
Light brown sugar.
Which, again, it's
this more earthy type.
Dirty Mint, as we call it.
In the standard
base recipe is just
plain white granulated sugar.
And when you are heating this
up, I'll show you the process,
but once it cools, you really
need about at least five hours
of it cooling to be able to
run in the ice cream maker.
So that's why it can be
like a two day process.
Maybe you want to make
the base before and not
churn it until the next day.
So, again, it just
requires some planning.
If you're having company over,
you want to make ice cream,
make the base either that
morning or the day before.
And then you can run it
perfectly the next day.
FREYA ESTRELLER: And then we can
follow along also in the book.
I think page 29 for
the plain custard base.
NATASHA CASE: OK.
So I have here my
two cups of cream.
Just want to measure it out.
We recommend organic
dairy, definitely.
So two cups of cream going in.
All right.
Next is two cups of whole milk.
If you're trying to prepare
for swimsuit season, which
I don't know why you would be
if you're making ice cream,
you can go half and
half or lighter milk.
It just won't be as
delicious in texture.
But you can kind of tone it
down a little bit on that.
Next goes in the sugar.
Freya's separating for me
about a cup and a quarter.
FREYA ESTRELLER: And for
the Dirty Mint recipe,
it's the light brown sugar,
not the white granulated.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
So, oh.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Oh, oops.
NATASHA CASE: Half.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Oh.
That's OK.
NATASHA CASE: So you're going
to put half of that total
on the burner with
the milk and cream.
And that's going to
kind of come together
and that's all on high heat.
The other half of
the sugar is going
to go separately in a
bowl with egg yolks.
I separated eight egg yolks.
And the egg yolks
are essentially
the stabilizer in the ice cream.
They are what's going to give
it the really nice rich texture.
If you ever have homemade
ice cream in a restaurant
or when you've made it at home
and it can get kind of icey,
that's essentially the dairy
separating from the ice.
And the eggs help
bind that together.
But the reason why we also
have half of the sugar
and the egg separately is that
what we're going to do next
is temper the eggs.
We don't want the eggs
to heat up too quickly
as the milk, cream, and
sugar is heating up.
Because then you're going to
get scrambled eggs ice cream
and nobody likes that.
Not even we can make
scrambled eggs ice cream good.
So as the cream, milk,
and sugar is heating up,
once I get it to
a light boil, then
I'm going to pour a
small amount of that
into the egg yolks and sugar.
And sort of gradually rise
the temperature of the eggs.
And this will make
them not scramble.
I would say that
the vast majority
of the time, the people feel the
most challenging part of making
ice cream is actually the base.
That the most mistakes
are with this part.
Once you get past
this, you're kind
of in the clear with throwing
mint leaves and chocolate
chips into your
ice cream machines.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Or alcohol.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Or
whatever you want.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah,
feel free to spike.
So yeah, I'm just going to
let this kind of heat up.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Cool.
So while this is
happening, we'll
just give a quick overview
on how we got started.
Right?
How did we go from Natasha doing
seven years of architecture
school to us having
Coolhaus in 2000 stores
all across the country.
Right?
So here we are in
one of our trucks.
We now have 11 in LA,
New York, Austin, Dallas.
NATASHA CASE: One is
visiting later today.
So.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Whoo!
Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: We all really
know why you're here, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
FREYA ESTRELLER: Just
let us get through this.
Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: Some food
porn for you, you know?
Some of our signature flavors.
You know, obviously, the
product is so, so key to us.
We really got
started just wanting
to make things from scratch.
And wanting to make a
product that we want to eat.
Also wanting to be
edgy and adventurous.
Freya and I both have pretty
sweet meets savory palates.
So doing things like
Beer and Pretzels,
or Fried Chicken
and Waffles, Brown
Butter Candied Bacon ice
cream, really just wanting
to push the envelope.
And also bring in the
architecture connection.
For me, coming out
of school, I just
felt like what was missing
with what we were studying
in architecture was
bridging it to the public
and making it really
fun and accessible.
So I had this crazy idea to
make ice cream and cookies
and name the combinations
after architects.
So that was also a big
part of the impetus
for us is to-- we were
on this kind of mission
with making
architecture digestible.
So the flavor on the top
is the I. M. Peanut Butter,
for example.
Which is a play on I. M. Pei.
Chocolate Peanut
Butter Cookie which
is now sold in Whole Foods.
You want to do the next?
So, yeah, I mentioned the
architecture part is really,
I think, a big thing that's made
Coolhaus really, really unique.
I sort of explain it like
Ben and Jerry's and Rock N'
Roll, or late night television.
For us, it's ice cream
and architecture.
It's a little more niche
than Rock N' Roll or TV,
but it works.
But it does give us this
whole other audience.
In terms of who's aware
of Coolhaus and people
really like, I think,
this other component.
And we do a lot of the
design for the packaging,
the website, the
store internally.
I do a lot of it myself.
So I think it gives the
brand a lot of authenticity
with the look and feel.
But a lot of famous architects
have been to Coolhaus
or know about it.
Here's Frank Gehry,
your very own.
Who's not very tall, as
you can see, at the truck.
He's lactose intolerant,
it turns out too.
So he couldn't eat his
flavor, which was unfortunate.
FREYA ESTRELLER: He also
made a really funny comment
at the truck.
He was like, you guys--
and this was at his office
here on the west
side-- and he was like,
you guys sure are making
a lot of money off of us.
And I was like, oh, no, like
off of starchitects in general?
Or just his office?
But we'll never know
what he meant by that.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA CASE: We still
think about it every morning
when we wake up.
[LAUGHTER]
There's also Thom
Mayne who did Caltrans.
and a lot of
international landmarks.
Most recently, Emerson
College, which is beautiful.
I don't know if you guys have
seen it on Sunset Boulevard.
But his flavor is
the Thom Mango.
So there he is with his
employees eating the sandwich.
So anyway, it's just
a really fun component
and I hope you enjoy that
part of the book, as well.
FREYA ESTRELLER: So
this is how we started.
This is what the truck
looked like when we bought it
for $2,900 on Craigslist.
[LAUGHTER]
It didn't drive.
We actually had to trick AAA
to tow it for us to Coachella.
Because we figured
out that if you
got the premiere membership,
you got two free 200 mile tows.
So--
NATASHA CASE: So
little bit of a scam.
FREYA ESTRELLER: So that's
how we got it there.
And those are all
of our ragtag group
of friends who we bribed
with free Coachella tickets.
NATASHA CASE: They're
not gang members.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: Contrary to--
FREYA ESTRELLER: To help
us work that weekend.
And we really went into
it not knowing very much
about how to run a food company.
I think we got there and then
realized we need at our booth,
because we had a booth too,
all four sides of the booth
had to be covered for
health regulations.
So we were like, what do we do?
We just grabbed tarps off
other people's vehicles
and started wrapping
our booth with it.
So really getting
bootstrappy with it.
NATASHA CASE: Quick break here.
This is the cream,
sugar, and milk.
It's hot enough.
It's at like a kind
of soft boil that I'm
going to pour
about a third of it
into my egg yolks and
light brown sugar.
Again, tempering the eggs
and stirring that gently.
Basically, you don't want to
cause like a major chemical
equation happening
with these egg yolks.
No scrambling.
So once I've got a nice
kind of pale yellow
and that's a little hard to see.
That's going to go
back into the pot.
And you can, can you just
turn it off basically.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah,
I turned it to 170.
NATASHA CASE: And
then you're going
to turn that pot onto
low so that it's now
really just all kind
of coming together,
but not on like a
high boil anymore.
FREYA ESTRELLER:
Yeah, so we want
to get it to between 165 and 180
which just thickens it enough.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
And pretty much all
that's left here
is just seeing that
it gets to that point.
And then you're going to take
it off the heat, let it chill,
and then it's going
to go into the fridge.
Really, minimum five
hours in the fridge.
But, again, overnight
would be ideal too.
And I also recommend
that you-- we're
pretty much there already.
At 170.
So you can go ahead
and turn this off.
I recommend that you, you know,
you can make the base in bulk.
So that you can use base for
multiple ice cream flavors.
So you could pick out like
two or three from the book
that you want to make.
80% of the recipes for the
ice cream use the same base.
So don't feel like
you have to make base
every time you want
to make a flavor.
You have three to five
days to use the base.
So, you know, again,
if you're smart
about it, just a
little bit of planning,
you can really make
it work and not
actually spend that much
time making ice cream.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah.
There's another shot
of the truck and kind
of like the spirit, and culture,
and vibe of our company.
And, of course, because we had
all those stickers on there,
people were asking us for
Bomb Pops and Choco Tacos,
and we were like, no, we
have architecturally themed,
all natural, gourmet ice cream.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're glad it resonated.
Obviously, learned a lot.
There was no signage.
No one knew who we were.
NATASHA CASE: So then we scraped
together the mild earnings
from Coachella and
it was time to fix up
the truck and brand it to
be Coolhaus and whatnot.
So we sent it to
east LA where a guy
named Junior, who was known in
the ice cream truck community
as being the person who
could sort of fix up
the aesthetics a little and
do some of the interior.
The truck lived over at his
shop for a couple weeks.
And by upgrade the
truck, basically we
mean add a door on it,
and an operable window,
and paint it silver.
And then actually our logo was
supposed to be done in vinyl.
You know, vector files that
said Coolhaus on the back.
It turned out, someone
just handpainted the logo.
So that, I guess, was a
little miscommunication.
But we felt that it
gave it a cool kind
of authentic feel anyway.
So we were able to hit
the streets with the truck
and start to get
the brand out there.
FREYA ESTRELLER:
And then in 2009,
end of 2009, because
he started April, 2009.
For those eight months, we
actually operated illegally.
Because when we
bought the truck,
we didn't realize that we
needed a bigger truck like that
to have the permit to do
made-to-order ice cream
sandwiches.
NATASHA CASE: And we
needed four sinks in there.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah,
we needed four sinks.
We only had one sink.
So we had a permit for
prepackaged ice cream.
And we were like, oh,
whatever, screw it.
We'll go out there anyway.
And thankfully, in
that eight months,
we were able to build our name,
get press, build a reputation.
And then we got caught
by the health department.
NATASHA CASE: Then we
were at First Friday.
And even then, even with
the incorrect permit
for what we were
doing, we were still
kind of chummy with
the health department.
And we were at First Friday.
And I actually
wasn't on the truck.
We had some of our employees,
AKA friends, on the truck.
And the health inspector
called me and said,
your guys are
scooping on the truck.
It's only supposed
to be pre-packaged.
And I was like,
are you kidding me?
I told them so many times
not to scoop ice cream.
How could they have done that?
[LAUGHTER]
They should only be
handing out pre-packaged.
I will definitely talk to them.
He was like, OK, just make
sure it doesn't happen again.
Fast forward a couple weeks,
I'm on the truck scooping ice
cream.
[LAUGHTER]
And they come up in their car
and totally caught red-handed.
I had a huge line,
but they didn't care.
They poured bleach in all
the tubs of ice cream.
And it was just a really sad,
humiliating day for Coolhaus.
And essentially, all said
and done, we worked it out
and they said, look, if you
want to be able to continue,
you have to get a
more functional--
FREYA ESTRELLER: And you
got put on probation.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
FREYA ESTRELLER: For
a couple of years.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA CASE: Yeah, it
was the case of Case.
That's my last name, Case.
And it ended up being just
kind of a-- we worked it out
in the end.
Actually, the public defense
that they assigned to me,
while the judge was reading
all the that we didn't have
the right sinks on the truck,
and all the violations,
she whispered into me
and she was like, so,
ice cream sandwiches, huh?
And I said, yeah.
And she said, how much are they?
I said, $5 each.
She said, do you
do kid's parties?
I was like, yeah,
here's my card.
[LAUGHTER]
That's how I knew we
were going to be OK.
FREYA ESTRELLER: That
forced us to really think
about the business
and also think
about how we were going
to grow it strategically.
And we knew that if we
wanted to get off the truck,
we needed multiple trucks
and multiple revenue streams.
So that we could
still pay ourselves
a salary without being
on the truck every day.
So we're glad that
that happened.
We raised-- you know, we did
a friends and family round.
Raised $30,000 from
friends and family.
Took on a hard money loan.
Because no one is going to be
loaning money to a business
that hasn't been in business
for more than two years.
I think the interest
rate was like 22%.
It was kind of crazy, but we
had to do what we had to do.
So that's actually
our second truck.
NATASHA CASE: Again, in front
of a Frank Gehry landmark.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: So not only
were we starting to scale,
but we were really starting
to specialize and develop
our niches for the brand.
Something that we didn't really
plan for in the beginning that
ended up being a huge
part of our business
was private catering.
And particularly in that
niche, actually, weddings
is our number one type of event.
We've done over 1,000 weddings.
They ended up being, I
think, a really good match
because of the customization
component of Coolhaus.
You know, pick your cookie,
pick your ice cream.
Everyone feels like they're
making their own unique treat
by doing that.
And part of the kind of
architectural thinking
with the product is
I wanted to rethink
the envelope with which
the sandwich is delivered.
And that's obviously
the packaging.
So came up with this idea
of the edible wrapper.
And there's kind of two points
that the edible wrapper brings
that are really,
really, I think,
exciting for
customers and clients.
One is the sustainability side.
If you're eating an ice cream
sandwich on the sidewalk
and you want to keep kind of a
clean environment, when you're
done eating the ice
cream sandwiches,
the edible wrapper essentially
sops up all the drippings.
And then you can just pop it
in your mouth and it dissolves.
And I also feel like
it's really hard
to find trash cans
in LA in general,
so that's just my pet peeve.
So it's a no waste product.
The other side is that we can
print on it with edible ink.
Soy-based ink.
So it's great for
corporate activations.
We should've put, we've done
a lot of Google activations
where we've had Google
Wallet on the edible wrapper.
Or when it was the operating
system ice cream sandwich,
I would have been offended
if we weren't invited
to come to Google and do
something special for that.
So we did a special
Android ice cream sandwich
on the edible wrapper.
But anyway, for weddings,
obviously, people
like to have that
customization side
and put their
monogram on something.
The edible wrapper
is perfect for that.
We have a lot of
brides and grooms
also, they want us
to print their faces
on the edible wrapper.
Which is sort of weird because
then you're eating their faces
or throwing away their faces.
But anyway, it's a really fun
kind of component of the brand.
FREYA ESTRELLER: And
then finally, we actually
did another, or I guess our
first angel investment round.
Because we wanted to
open up a storefront.
At that point, we
had a couple trucks.
We were looking to expand into
New York City with a couple
trucks.
And that's our Culver City
storefront right there.
And, of course, with all
startups and businesses,
you come across a lot
of bumps in the road.
It didn't work out with
our first angel investor.
As we started progressing
forward with him,
we realized it
wasn't a good fit.
And thankfully our lawyer
had wrote something
in the agreement that if we
didn't take all the money
by a certain amount of time, the
equity converted back to debt.
Which was awesome.
So we got to keep our
equity, no longer work
with that angel investor, now
it just turned into a loan.
And then, while we were under
construction in Culver City--
so it was kind of
a stressful time.
We had to stop construction,
we came across Bobby Margolis,
who was Natasha's dad's client.
Natasha's dad is
also an architect.
And Bobby used to
own Cherokee jeans.
And he was looking to invest
in a cool startup brand.
NATASHA CASE: And he was
particularly interested in--
we had just gone into
a few Whole Foods
when we were connected to him.
I did a three store test in
Venice, Glendale, and Pasadena.
It was doing really well.
So we were already
starting to grow there.
For us, at the time,
we just thought,
the Whole Food
accounts were good,
but they were slightly annoying.
We had to meet all
their criteria,
and do all these
deliveries, and it
seemed like a really small,
nothing side of the business.
However, he really
saw the potentially
and the scalability.
FREYA ESTRELLER:
Yeah, we came to him
with financial projections for
two trucks in every major city.
We were like, Chicago,
Miami, St. Louis, Atlanta.
And he was like, no, ladies.
No, no, no.
We're going to become
the next Ben and Jerry's.
Are you guys ready for that?
Like we're going to go to
Whole Foods, Sprouts, Bristol
Farms, [INAUDIBLE], et
cetera, and we were like,
but this is so annoying.
Like putting it
together and everything.
But fast forward a couple years
later and that is definitely
our goal is to be the
next Ben and Jerry's.
There's some of our--
that's a happy employee.
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA CASE: Well, to
the point with the-- we
like having the different
sides of the business.
At this point, the
trucks are the marketing
and on the ground, boutique
side of the brands.
The stores are great
for sort of showcasing
the whole vision of what we're
about and the company culture.
It's a place where everyone
can sort of see and know
each other.
We have our storage there,
our office headquarters,
and the trucks load
in and out of there.
So it created just
like a centralized hub
for Coolhaus company culture.
And I feel like that's
when the brand really
matured to the next level.
We do now have 70
employees nationwide.
And they all hold their
hands a bit in the air
and look excited all the time.
We do also have another store
in Pasadena in Old Town.
It's actually a
shared marketplace,
it's a very cool
space on Colorado.
I highly recommend
you guys check it out.
Piehole is in there, Pressed.
There's a flower company
coming in, a spice company.
So that's been good to have
on two different sides of LA.
Different brick
and mortar retail.
FREYA ESTRELLER: And with this,
with the design we worked with,
I don't know if you guys have
heard of the Design, bitches?
NATASHA CASE: Design,
comma, bitches.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Comma.
Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: Like we're
the bitches, not them.
[LAUGHTER]
But they did our
Culver City store,
they did Superba, both
Superbas, Oinkster.
They're very cool.
Majorly up and coming
architecture firm.
Two ladies that
we're friendly with.
So this just sort of maps
out some of the growth.
We are pretty
ambitious and Coolhaus.
We've doubled or
tripled every year
in terms of our
reach and revenue.
But you can see how at
the beginning, trucks
and scaling the trucks,
then diversifying more
with brick and mortar and
wholesale distribution.
Then really focusing on
wholesale distribution
and diversifying that.
I think the later
slides will show
we kind of fine
tuned our packaging.
Yeah, we started with
that box in the lower left
which was really hard
to read from the shelf.
And all the flavors just
had a black and white label
saying what each
different flavor was.
So you literally couldn't tell--
like, we couldn't have made it
harder for people
to know what it was
and what the different
flavors were.
But we still made it
past that initial test
and were doing well
enough, but by the time
we introduced the new packaging,
which is like a shiny aluminum
bag, it looks like the
truck with the grill
and headlights on there.
And the windshield.
It's a little hard to see there,
but really bright, fun colors.
It's a more
affordable packaging.
It's more differentiated
on the shelf.
They started performing--
FREYA ESTRELLER: Our
sales increased by 500%.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
FREYA ESTRELLER: So
just, but for here,
this is just our getting
to minimum viable product,
getting it out there,
measuring the feedback,
revising the product,
making it better, and just
like the whole notion of
action, not perfection
when you're starting something.
Like you just have
to get it out.
And so we're glad that we did.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
And actually I had interns--
we had more toned down colors
even on the shiny bags.
And I had my interns last
summer go to Whole Foods
and just kind of ask
people anonymously
what packages they were
attracted to on the shelves.
Or what kind of color schemes.
And shockingly, everyone
likes bright, shiny objects
with fun, bright colors.
So I was like, oh.
So anyway, we're
really continuing
the kind of more bright
yellow, the purple, the pink.
Really fun.
And I think for me, as
an architect designing
this product, as opposed to
a consumer packaged goods
designer, it doesn't
look different and weird.
But that's what
makes them stand out.
So I think by not playing to
the generally accepted status
quo, just kind of
doing our own thing.
We've kind of walked
through some walls
because we didn't
know they were there.
And that's what's made
the brand succeed.
The next step is now
getting outside of the-- you
don't want to be a one trick
pony with ice cream sandwiches.
So the pints are new this year.
They kind of look like fun
paint buckets, in my opinion.
But it's a
semi-transparent package
so you can see the ice
cream on the inside.
And just fun bright colors
that speak to the brand.
The bars also are out this year.
The flavors are really
sweet meets salty.
One of them's
Tahitian vanilla bean
dipped in salted caramel milk
chocolate rolled in pretzels.
Ones like a Nutella bar and
salted chocolate and almonds.
One's coffee Oreo
and salted chocolate.
And then another
really important way
that we diversified
is this book.
What's really amazing and fun
about the book is it sort of
brings everything full circle.
As much as we can get the
prepackaged sandwiches
to as many people as
possible with distribution,
this is a whole other way to
bring our product home to you.
You can make it
at home yourself.
And these are really
our homemade recipes
more that we started with.
And a lot of insight
into way more
flavors, obviously, than
we can ever put on a shelf.
So we just love, again,
bringing the product
to as many people as possible.
The book has been such an
incredible way to do that.
And I know and think you
guys will really enjoy it.
So yeah.
FREYA ESTRELLER: As we
wait for this ice cream
to harden a little bit more.
Do you guys have
any questions for us
before we try some of this and
then release you to the truck?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
NATASHA CASE: It's
getting there.
And by the way,
we're just trying
to get this to like
soft serve texture.
And then it goes in the freezer.
You don't eat it right
out of the machine.
FREYA ESTRELLER: But you can.
NATASHA CASE: I mean,
there's no hard rules here.
Like, you can't go wrong.
All right, yes.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this thing on?
Yes.
I see you guys in a lot
of tech-related events.
Is that something you targeted
explicitly or [INAUDIBLE]?
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA CASE: You know, I would
say that Coolhaus lends itself
so well to so many
different worlds.
We've done a lot with
fashion and entertainment,
a lot with tech.
It's just people who
are forward thinking
and who want to be adventurous
about what they're eating.
That's what we really got
into with the ice cream.
Is that it has such a broad
reach and broad appeal.
But I will say we also,
I think, set up the brand
so that it is a good
canvas for other brands.
Like things like
the edible wrapper.
The trucks get branded a lot.
Totally like the staff,
whatever a brand wants
them to wear in an activation,
I'm like, they're all yours.
Don't tell them I said that.
I'm like, they'll wear an
apron and a hat or whatever.
So we do, I think,
mesh well with a lot
of different types of companies.
It really just has to do with
enjoying good food and, again,
being adventurous
with what you like
to eat as far as ice cream.
AUDIENCE: So I couldn't help
but notice the "Dexter" wrapper.
[LAUGHTER]
So what's the story
behind that? [INAUDIBLE].
NATASHA CASE: Yeah,
I mean I think
that is a really good sequitur
from the last question.
So last year, we
actually got approached
by Showtime for the
finale season of "Dexter"
to do something really special
to kind of commemorate it
and see it off.
And they came to us,
I feel, very much
because we have
the boutique side
with the trucks and
the brick and mortar.
And the innovation and the
kind of small team who can
think big, the cool
flavors, but we also
have a more growing
national business
arm, which was that
wholesale distribution.
So they saw us as the
company they could partner
up with that could do a
little bit of both for them.
So what we did is they
kind of commissioned
us to do a flavor
for that season.
You've got to be a little
careful with the murder and ice
cream theme.
You know, that can be touchy.
[LAUGHTER]
But at South by
Southwest in 2013,
we had the Bloody Orange
which was blood orange.
And then we had the Killer Combo
which was Tahitian vanilla bean
with a bloody cherry swirl
with two different cookies.
The two sides of Dexter.
And we did sort of a test
at South by Southwest
in an event to see
which was more popular.
The Killer Combo won.
So we had that at our
stores all summer.
They wrapped our trucks
in LA and New York
and we did like 50 hours
of giveaway on the streets
to promote that flavor
and the finale season.
We had one of the
detectives on the truck.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Masuka?
NATASHA CASE: Yeah, Masuka?
I don't know if
you watch the show.
FREYA ESTRELLER:
I forget his name.
NATASHA CASE: Giving it away.
So that was fun, kind
of celebrity angle.
And then we did a
pre-packaged version.
Actually designed the bag for
them because that's what I do.
And we took it to all
of our trade shows
where we work with
retailers and they loved it.
So so many stores,
like Whole Foods
here in southern
California, Sprouts,
tons of markets around the
country ended up picking it up.
And it was sold in grocery
all over the country.
And then also we had it
available for shipping online.
A lot of people ordered
it in our online store.
And we shipped it out to them.
So it was just an amazing way
to partner with another brand,
showcase us, and showcase them.
And do something really cool.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but how did
you learn how to make ice cream?
[LAUGHTER]
NATASHA CASE: In studio.
You know, I think that's
also a big point of the book.
our feeling is we
don't want to make
it intimidating
and unapproachable.
Ice cream is fun.
And if we can do it and we
don't have a formal cooking
background, you
guys can do it too.
And I think once you get the
basics of ice cream, literally,
the base down, it's
just such a great canvas
for innovation
and experimenting.
And you can do a lot
with it without being
like a trained pastry chef.
So I think you can get one
good cookbook like ours
and you can really
teach yourself.
And get to be quite an
expert at it pretty quickly.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah, actually
the Dirty Mint that we're doing
was actually an accident.
Or sort of like part
laziness, part accident.
We looked up a recipe--
NATASHA CASE: Like
all good things.
FREYA ESTRELLER: For
mint chip ice cream.
And randomly it was,
like, who was it?
Something like Isaac
Mizrahi's mint chip ice cream.
So random.
And it called for straining
the mint leaves out
of the ice cream.
And we were just kind
of lazy, or forgot,
or didn't read the instructions
well, and left it in.
And then it called for
white granulated sugar,
but we ran out.
And only had light brown sugar.
And this is where the
laziness comes in.
We didn't want to go out
to get the white sugar.
We're like let's just use brown.
And then when we tried it with
that combo and the mint left
in, you guys will try it,
it's a whole nother world
of mint chip ice cream.
So it was happy accidents
like that where we realized
like, oh, we can really
just get creative with this.
NATASHA CASE: The cookies
are a little harder.
I'm not going to lie.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Do you
use cream that's
ultra-pasteurized
or [INAUDIBLE] which
flavor difference in ice cream?
NATASHA CASE: Yeah, not
necessarily ultra-pasteurized.
I think less
processed is better.
And you want it to
be on the fresh side.
Also the eggs should be
not on their way out.
I've even made ice cream with
raw dairy before, actually.
Which I thought was delicious.
And that goes bad
really quickly.
So I just had to find
a good use for it.
And to that point, a fun tip
from the book is with sorbets,
they're a great thing to do with
fruit when it's on its way out.
Like how it's sort of famous
that you make banana bread
with bananas as
they're almost rotting.
Fruit when it's almost
past the point of even just
wanting to eat it on its
own is perfect for sorbet.
Because it has the
highest sugar content.
So I actually find
that ice cream
is a really great utilitarian
way of not wasting products.
Whether it's the dairy or fruit
that you could throw away.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Awesome.
Well, I think, I--
NATASHA CASE: Yeah, we're
getting pretty close here.
Perfect timing.
FREYA ESTRELLER: We're
getting really close.
And maybe if we can get
some spoons off the truck
or is there, do you guys have
little like taster spoons?
I totally forgot about that.
I want you guys to come up
here and taste the base.
So you guys know
what the base should
taste like and the consistency.
And that also taste the homemade
Dirty Mint Chip ice cream,
which you guys will be
able to make at home.
NATASHA CASE: On
the other side, I
don't know if there's any,
like, beer snobs out there.
We wanted to do this chocolate
stout ice cream with pretzels.
And we told one of our kind
of non-beer snob, slightly
non-foodie employees to go and
get like a chocolate stout.
Try to find Rasputin if you can.
And he instead
decides to buy Spaten.
I don't know if you know, It's
sort of like German Corona
basically.
FREYA ESTRELLER:
It's like a lager.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
And just brought it
directly to the facility
and they started running it.
And so when we got
that, when it was done
and we were tasting
it, I'm like,
something is wrong
with this beer.
Or it just.
FREYA ESTRELLER: You could
tell it was light-colored.
It's supposed to be like this
dark, rich chocolatey color.
You're like, wait a minute.
NATASHA CASE: He couldn't
understand the difference
basically.
For us, it was
like night and day.
So it was very-- and I tried
to give that ice cream away.
The Spaten ice cream to
different employees or friends.
And for some reason, it kept
ending up back in the freezer.
[LAUGHTER]
It was like we couldn't
get rid of it if we tried.
It kept showing up again.
So it kind of became the bane.
But those were, you know,
it's a rare full-on failure
when it comes to ice cream.
You can really
push it quite far.
We have the Peking Duck ice
cream which works great.
White Chocolate Olive,
that's a weird one.
It's delicious, I promise you.
So it's really, it's hard
to have a complete fail.
Write to me if you fail hardcore
and we'll talk about it.
[LAUGHTER]
FREYA ESTRELLER:
Awesome, well, yeah, I--
NATASHA CASE: One other
thing I want to mention too,
by the way, you have
your books, but the ebook
is also really cool.
It's a lot of the content
from the cookbook obviously.
But the enhancement
is the audio.
Which we focus for
the ebook, since it's
on iBooks and iTunes.
On the music side of Coolhaus--
you want to go to that slide?
FREYA ESTRELLER: Yeah.
NATASHA CASE: This
is our Austin General
Manager with Tegan and Sarah.
We have this up here
as an example of we
do a lot of-- music is
really important at Coolhaus.
It's a big part of our brand.
I think Michael Allen's
on the truck, right?
FREYA ESTRELLER: Mhm.
NATASHA CASE: We have a lot of
employees-- including Michael
Allen, you can
ask him about it--
on the truck who are musicians.
We're very supportive
of what they do.
We've done Coolhaus
playlists where
we feature all of our different
employees who are in bands.
Like, you know, top songs.
And we play that from the
trucks and the stores.
And we partner with a
lot of musical artists
to do special sandwiches for
them at ACL, at Coachella,
or for certain good
causes with them.
We did a marriage equality
sandwich called Till Death
Do Us Part, double chocolate
cookie, salted caramel ice
cream.
And we've kind of
gone on tour with them
at the Hollywood Bowl, at
the Greek theater, at ACL.
And handed away the sandwich
in the name of that good cause.
So in the ebook,
there's little anecdotes
that I tell about the
different musical artists
that we've teamed up with
and what their flavors are
that we've done with them.
And then it connects to playlist
by those artists in iTunes.
So just as a whole kind of
cool other angle on Coolhaus.
As though we needed
to be cooler.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just kidding.
But anyway, it's fun.
So would recommend
the, I just wanted
to mention why the ebook is
a little different if you're
interested too.
FREYA ESTRELLER: Awesome.
Well, yeah, I'd
love for you guys
to come up here and try
the base and the ice cream.
And then the truck is outside.
NATASHA CASE: Yeah.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]